many people have been asking me about
the Floyd money Mayweather fight vs
Conor McGregor probably because of my
years of experience in the martial arts
they wonder my perspective now before I
get to that let me ask you a question
and I want you to come on a ride a
journey with me and I need you to use
your imagination the same way you use it
for other things I really need you to
capitalize on this by really putting
yourself in the picture that I'm going
to paint I want you to imagine having
all of the money that Conor McGregor and
Floyd money Mayweather are gonna make
you know they're gonna make over a
hundred million dollars in just this one
fight now on top of that go ahead and
add all of the money that Floyd has also
made over the years and Connor's made
put all that together and now put
yourself on a luxurious huge enormous
the biggest yacht make it as big as you
want and put yourself on a huge
beautiful luxurious plane either one
whatever you feel more comfortable with
whatever you like with all the amenities
now I need you to envision waking up on
your plane superduper playing and or
luxurious yacht with all the amenities
and all the cash baby you got it you
made it you woke up with it but you're
lost you're lost in the air or you're
lost in the sea and remember that you
can kick it as they say have a good time
enjoy with all the amenities you got all
the luxuries or you can really think
about how in the world did I end up in
this place where I'm at and do you think
how much it does this money actually
mean to you how much would it be worth
to you think about that for a moment
really ponder and think what would this
be worth to me and then I want you to
equate it what is it that space that you
occupy on that yacht compared to the
vast ocean or the sea or how about the
plane that you're flying in what does
that occupy next to the air to the left
to the right upper below get that that
huge vast picture in your mind so does a
person continue to be entertained by all
the amenities and all the luxuries on
that ship that boat that yacht or that
plane or there's this or does a serious
person start to really reflect and think
how did I end up here I better hurry up
and figure out how am I gonna land this
thing because eventually it's gonna end
it's gonna fall out of the sky
or it's gonna be overtaken by the sea
and it's gonna sink now that's no
different if you really think about this
and it gets deep it's no different than
this small space that we occupy on this
earth in the whole galaxy and the earth
that is spinning in it and many of us
we've been numb to the fact that we are
here for a short amount of time and it's
one spectacle to the next so people are
living from one boxing match to the next
MMA event to the next golf to the next
Super Bowl to the next weekend and the
list goes on now would you do that on
the plane knowing that it can fall from
the sky it can sink in the ocean at any
time what's all that money that you got
all their money Floyds and Connor's on
the plane you've hit it big now but it
can all end at any time wouldn't you
take the matter more serious that's my
question to you shouldn't we ponder and
think deeper than the material things
and that money
that money that they'll make wishing
that you had it and in the same way many
people are blasting their boom boxes in
their fancy cars which or in their
beater cars fantasizing having the fancy
cars fantasizing having the girls girls
fantasizing having the boys and the
clothes in the fashion and everything
else the material things the things that
are going to perish the things that are
temporary so that's my perspective from
one end then when we see that that we
really ponder and think now some people
might say well I mean what's wrong with
entertainment I'm not talking about that
everything in a balance if it's
something that is decent it's not
immoral no problem in a balance but if
you just continue to live from one
spectacle to the next from one
entertainment boxing show to the next
without thinking like I'm gonna continue
spinning on this earth for a short
duration it's gonna end soon and don't
fool yourself and become complacent and
think that well I'll just figure it out
when I get there who lives their life
like that who plans to go on a trip and
doesn't get a visa to that country
thinking like well I'll just get over
there and I'll figure it out
I mean only a fool does that so don't
expect to live life and die and just say
well I'll figure it out what is on the
other side when I get there it's too
late then you got one shot here and the
intelligent person has many smart people
but the intelligent person reflects
thinks everything around us has a
purpose but what about the human being
that's wearing the boxing gloves that's
wearing the boxing shorts those shorts
have a purpose the boxing gloves have a
purpose the 8-ounce gloves they have a
purpose the shoes have a purpose the
tile that the boxers use everything has
a purpose the ring they're dancing
around tonight will have a purpose
what about those two individuals playing
the game imagined at the end there was
no rounds there was no time limit limit
there was no objective to that boxing
match which there is but there's no
objective to life that doesn't make
sense so there's a lot of smart people
but the intelligent person wants to know
wants to know why they here where they
going when they're died and they asked
and this is what I want you to I want to
give you some homework it's really
simple it's not something weird bizarre
far-fetched way out there is to within
yourself to ask the one who puts you
here the ultimate reality the creator
ask within yourself so why am I here
what do you want from me something is
simple with that begin with that and
begin on a quest to explore and to want
to know generally sincerely the purpose
of life while asking the owner of life
how about that
so in conclusion my thoughts my
perspective on the Floyd money
Mayweather an a Conor McGregor fight is
may God Almighty may the Almighty
guiding both to be true no matter who
wins or loses that they take the Muslim
American Hero as a role model the one
who was in their shoes at one time now
he's also gone Muhammad Ali who millions
upon millions of people were affected by
the example that he left behind by the
charity by the humanitarian work and he
wasn't shy to talk about purpose to
invite people to the purpose might make
y'all thing
life is real short so yeah if all your
traveling and I bought you sleeping
and I bought you school and I bought you
entertainment you probably been half
your life doing nothing so what am i
I'll I'm 35 years old 30 more years I'll
be 65 we don't have no more influence we
can't do nothing bunch of 65 vy4 tell
you that
so once am when you're 65 when you're 65
ain't too much more to do so did you
know I'll be 65 in 30 more years in
those thirty years after sleep 9 years I
don't have 30 years of daylight I have
to travel back to America take six seven
miles all my traveling probably four
years of traveling next 30 years about
nine years of sleeping television movies
entertained by three years of
entertainment out of 30 years I might
have about 16 years to be productive so
it's how we can all break individual
lives now what am I going to do the next
16 years what's the best thing I can do
get ready to meet God owning real estate
dwelling business teaching boxes that
won't get me to heaven and to look into
the way of life that motivated him to
live that purpose of life that he was
upon and that's how they can truly leave
a a legacy behind a real legacy behind
all the glitz and the glamor and then
detainment in the spectacle and the cars
and the shows and all these other
useless things that we're going to leave
behind when we depart and die
we can't take none of it with us think
about it and I'm signing out thank you
very much peace be with you
Sonic
you